في هذا المنبر احب اشكر الجمهور اللي كان
جدا جدا
جدا واقف معنا في هذه الفترات الحمد لله
المنتخب القطري قاعد يمشي خطوه بخطوه وهذا
اهم
شيء الفوز اليوم يعطينا دافع ايضا معنا
وان احنا نتقدم للامام اللي هي البطوله
نهائي عربي عربي اعتقد ان هذا شيء جدا
مشرف للكره العربيه ولا تقليلا
في المدرسه الاخرى لكن الحمد لله
اعتقد نهائي عربي عربي بيكون جدا جدا جميل
وان شاء الله احنا ان احنا بنحاول نقدم كل
ما عندنا اكيد المباراه كانت جدا صعبه
المنتخب الايران نفس ما قلت هو بالنسبه لي
من اقوى المنتخبات حاليا في اسيا ان لم
يكن الافضل الحمد لله عرفنا نستغل نقاط
ضعفهم عرفنا نسجل عرفنا نركز كنا نلعب
بروح قتاليه بحماس وهاي اللي فرق معانا في
هذه المباراه وعرفنا نستغل الفرص والحمد
لله فخورين بما قدمناه اكيد انجاز كبير
وصلنا للنهائي للمره الثانيه على التوالي
وباذن الله ان نكون قدها و نحرز اللقب على
المره الثانيه على التوالي الحمد لله على
الفوز والوصول للنهائي احب ابارك لجمهورنا
احب ابارك حق الشعب
الاطريق الكامل
طبعا المره الثانيه على التوالي نهائي كاس
اسيا طبعا شيء كبير فخر بالنسبه لنا
طموحنا كبير ان شاء الله نفوز في النهائي